January 1995 The Outlaws led by national
president taco Bowman have become the
most violent motorcycle club in the
United States in Florida rival bikers
are assaulted enemy Clubhouse is bombed
and local businesses are targeted in a
campaign of intimidation and terror the
outlaws Daytona chapter is called to
Indiana to attend the funeral of outlaw
member Donald fog never died it was a
mandatory run to appear at the brothers
funeral if you didn't show up you had to
have good reason not to either you'd
have to be in the hospital or in jail
hogs corpse was found facedown in a
field cause of death a single gunshot to
the head
at the funeral taco Bowman lays the
blame on the Hells Angels but the
evidence doesn't add up
fog had a loaded pistol in his jacket
pocket
it appears Foggs murderer was someone he
trusted
Big Al believes Bowman himself ordered
the hit they say was in house and said
he was killed because he was talking to
the feds
arrested for his part in the Lancaster
Speedway fight rumor has it that Donald
Fogg was snitching to save his own neck
when they come back from the funeral
everybody came back in they throw at a
newspaper up on the counter there and
there was an article about an FBI
informant that got killed the Daytona
Outlaws will target any snitch they find
although on high alert they fail to
realize there's a snitch in their midst
and the FBI are listening to their every
word despite the danger Mike Wynn now
has a real sense of purpose he comes up
with a plan to improve the surveillance
and enable the FBI to follow activities
outside the clubhouse I figured well if
we had a really nice van all the guys
wanted to ride around in and party in
this would be the perfect setup
the FBI gives Michael in money to
purchase a van which is rigged with
recording equipment now you've got the
entire club sitting in this van all
talking about criminal activity
FBI procedure does not allow Mike Lynn
to touch the tapes or even to know
exactly where the Vans recording
equipment is located if you do somebody
else they want to take custody of the
tape as fast as they can that way they
have chain-of-command on a tape Wynn
must alert Tim Donovan when a recording
is finished in a designated parking spot
Donovan must enter the van in privacy
and take possession of the taped
evidence Mike Lynn had just completed a
very good recording of several of the
members planning some criminal activity
Mike's recordings reveal a plot to
murder a rival warlocks chapter
president in Brevard County Florida
we followed in the waters houses all
right it is greater than 15 the tape is
dynamite but Lin can't seem to get away
from D Calum onion when Mike is sent to
buy food for an outlaws club party it's
his only chance to swap the tapes with
the feds I did my thing mr. Donovan was
out inside the van doing whatever he
does in there in secrecy
I quickly worked on be winding the reel
in order to place a fresh reel of tape
in and I heard motorcycles
and it wasn't just a motorcycle if it
was a lot of motorcycles I'd come
outside and here's the guys up by the
van and say Oh
Tim's inside the van you know what do I
do I'm sitting in the van the game you
know I guess what I do is I just say
okay it's it's over FBI you know when I
take my chances that way you get talking
they came over and started checking out
seeing all the groceries and junk that I
had you know like a bunch of little kids
I go oh you got this and that's good i
peeped through the curtain I observe
members now focusing on Mike Lynn I
jumped out I ran as fast and as far as I
possibly could luckily that gave Tim
enough time to get out there take off
like a little rabbit now on down the
road
Donovan escapes with the evidence but
it's the last time the pair arrange a
rendezvous in a public place